but
mistakes
make you strong hey guys in the old days
it was expected
of men to pay for dates because
back then they were the ones that worked
a lot
and most women they stay at home to take
care
of the kids and to do house chores but
now
we live in the 21st century men and
women
both work and now the question is
who should pay for dates men
women or both well it depends on a lot
of things
it's never just black and white my
personal opinion
if you asked a woman out then you gotta
pay for it because you asked her out
especially if it's a first date
but then i would also expect a good
woman
to also make a gesture an offer to also
pay
for the bill or to at least split it
because that gesture that offer is a lot
more important to me
than the money because it shows me what
type of woman
she really is but what do most people
think
about this in a survey on love and
finances conducted by money and survey
monkey
78 of people said they think men should
pay for the first
day now just hear me out we live in a
day and age where
both work men and women some women make
a lot more money
than men and they say we should be
treated equally and fair
and of course i agree i fully agree with
it
but then when it comes to dating somehow
it all changes
then we're not treated fair and equally
anymore and then most women want
men to pay for dates most women do not
want to pay for dates
or at least just pay half or just chip
in a little bit
now don't get me wrong good men will
always offer to pay
for the day but a good woman would do it
as well or at least just to pay half of
it just to split the bill
if an if a woman never offers to chip in
then the guy would think man is this is
this really how it's going to be if we
get more
serious or even merry later on is she
never going to pay for anything
she just wants me to pay for all of it
maybe i should not marry her that's not
fair according to scientific american
64 of men expect their partner to chip
in
which is unfortunate for the 44
of women who are bothered when a man
expects them to pay
their share so over half of women
think they should never offer to pay
they don't really care
okay now hear me out i believe in being
a gentleman
i believe i'm a little bit more
old-fashioned but i believe that men
should pay for the date but i also think
that some women
will take advantage of it and that's not
fair
it's hypocritical of those types of
women who say that men and women should
be treated equally
but then they shouldn't be treated
equally when it comes
to dating then they want the guy to pay
for every day that they go on
they might not even be that interested
in the guy
they might just mislead him they're not
interested in it but they are
very interested in a free night out
free food and free drinks so with all
that being said
be a gentleman pay for the day
especially
if you asked her out but then also
choose the right
woman if you've been dating a woman for
a while now
for a few months and she never even
offers to chip in
and you know she makes a lot of money
maybe even more than you
then maybe you should not be dating her
money does not just grow on trees we all
work very hard
for the money that we have according to
the new york post the average american
spends
121 000 on dating in their lifetime
a poll of 2 000 americans found that on
average
dating will cost 168 dollars a month
and 185 dollars for married couples
that's a lot is it worth it well of
course it is
if you date the right person
look love is one of the best most
amazing experiences
that you can have in this temporary
world so don't waste
your time don't waste your life and
don't date the wrong people that might
take advantage
of you and if you believe in god and you
want relationship advice
and please watch one of these videos
here they're from my other channel
called dlm christian lifestyle and i'll
see you there
cheers guys